patrick corbin suffered the loss last
start against the marlins on september
18th jd davis is trying to fight out of
an over 19
funk that's true
off the bag and that goes down the line
and davis breaks the o for 19 by hitting
the cushion
the throw from left field by taylor and
davis slides in safely
with a pin cushion double
that's what the gnats needed an easy out
to end the inning
corbin takes care of that david peterson
just outstanding in his last start six
innings
ten strikeouts
[Applause]
right back to the mound and peterson
makes the play on suzuki
and that retires a son but it's two on
nobody out
and the first pitch a changeup he pops
it up
midfield fly rule in effect jake mull
catches it one out
there you go six four three turner
garcia
and noel and patrick corbin always one
pitch away from being out of the inning
oh nowhere to go slider down and in
look at him go and the dugout loves it
he overruns first base josh harrison the
best hit by pitch i've ever seen
you remember that rule is it one of the
the independent leagues last year that
if the ball went to the backstop you
could do this and try to beat it out
in addition to everything else lined
toward the middle and he's got to base
it
harrison to second he'll turn and try
for third dom makes the throw to third
base and it's on target and he's out
harrison going aggressively trying to go
first to third on a base hit to left
and dom smith guns him down for the
second out
half swing did he go he did strike three
and peterson's got his first strike out
of the night
another hard hit ball soto back for this
one and he's got it
he'll just turn his back and bump up
against the delta sign
a ball in flight and he took it away two
down
well here's alonzo again
3-2 and he didn't chop anything but air
on that pitch
93 on the sinking fastball two
he gets garcia looking at a fastball and
that's his second strikeout
long-legged left-hander comes home
breaking balls cut on and miss strike
three turner punches out
and peterson works a one-two-three
inning suzuki at second and here's
harrison
there's a ball to left center that'll
put the nets on top
suzuki scores easily josh harrison his
12th rbi
one nothing washington ready at first
nobody out three and two to torinos he's
running
and torino's lifts it out to right
center back in the gap goes soto near
the wall
and it's out of here robinson chorinos
with an
opposite field two run homer and the
mets go in front two to one
chirinos with his first home run of the
season
his first home run as a met and it's a
big one it gives the mints the lead
drag recall on the inside edge
matcha corbin with some paint for his
second
strike
served right field slicing
soto in the corner jumps and makes the
play
comes up throwing a one hopper to second
safe on a close play he almost
engineered
a 9-6 double play both runners tagging
and moving up
so now torinos who hit the two-run homer
to get the mets the lead has a chance to
do some more damage
torinos rolls one on the right side noel
the only guy there has to hit the
pitcher on
on the move and he can't get it there in
time and a run comes home
so three rbis tonight for robinson
chirinos that'll get
scored as an infield hit david peterson
who has been outstanding allowed just
two hits seventh pitch of the at-bat and
gomes hits one past the mound
charging canoe sidearm throw gets him to
end the inning
so peterson works around another double
he's gone six innings for a second
straight start
pace is loaded that's patrick corbin's
third walk of the night
in there with the fastball nice
matt jacob working hard to get through
seven
for the first time in his major league
career david peterson will throw a pitch
in the seventh inning
two-two in the dirt swinging a missed
strike three
it's a breaking ball but it was way out
in front of the plate and noel chased it
anyway so peterson gets a big
strikeout and he grounds one down to
first
alonso makes the play himself and david
peterson gets through
seven innings
[Applause]
slicing and
michael a over the rail to pull it in
that's a tall wall with a rail on top of
it
that was awesome and edwin diaz will bid
for the save
24 innings with 48 punch-outs just
numbers not used to seeing
now it's 0-2 to thames
struck him out 100-mile an hour fastball
up out of the zone that's her down to
their final out with
yadiel hernandez
wellhead basic left field chip hale
sending stevenson all the way four rbis
in short order now for yadiel hernandez
one two coming grounded right side
jimenez in front of it
and the ball game is over edwin diaz
gives up rwanda registers the save david
peterson completes his rookie year with
a brilliant seven inning outing